PROFESSOR: Hi everyone.
So today, I'd like to talk
about frequency response.
And specifically,
we're going to take
a look at a couple different
differential equations.
And we're asked to graph
the amplitude response
for each equation.
And you'll note that these
equations a, b and c have
varying amounts of damping.
So for part a we're asked to
plot the amplitude response
for x dot dot plus 4x
equals F_0 cosine omega*t.
For part b it's
the same equation,
however we have an
x dot term added.
For part c, again we've
increase the damping.
So now we have 6x dot.
And then lastly for
part d, we'd like
to discuss the resonance
for each system.
So I'll let you work
out this problem,
and I'll be back in a moment.
Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So for part a, we're asked to
graph the amplitude response
to the differential equation
x dot dot plus 4x equals F_0
cosine omega*t.
And from a previous
recitation, we already
wrote down the
particular response
to this differential equation.
So I'm just going to write
down the particular response,
which has the form F_0 4 minus
omega squared cosine omega*t.
Now the amplitude response
is defined as a ratio,
and specifically it's the
ratio of the output amplitude
of a differential equation
to the input amplitude
of a differential equation.
So in the case at hand,
we have the output
is a sinusoidal function
whose amplitude is F_0 divided
by 4 minus omega squared.
So it's the output
divided by the input.
These are both amplitudes.
And in our case,
we have F_0 divided
by 4 minus omega squared.
This is the output amplitude.
And the input
amplitude is just F_0.
So we see when we compute this
ratio the F_0's divide out.
And at the end of
the day, we're left
with 4 minus omega squared.
So I'm going to draw the
amplitude response now.
So we have omega.
And we see that when
omega is equal to 2,
there's an asymptote.
When omega is equal
to 0, we have 1/4.
And specifically, we have
this tent-like function.
So this is the
amplitude response.
So notice how when we drive
the system with frequency two,
the amplitude response
goes to infinity.
As a result, we
call this frequency
the resonant frequency.
So this concludes part a.
For part b, we have a
differential equation
with damping now.
And to compute the
particular solution,
we follow the standard
procedure of first complexifying
the right-hand side and then
using the exponential response
formula.
So I'm just going to write
down the particular solution.
If we follow these steps, we
find that it's the real part
of the right-hand
side complexified,
which is F_0 e to the i*omega*t
divided by the characteristic
polynomial evaluated at i*omega.
And in this case, the
characteristic polynomial p
of s is s squared plus s plus 4.
p of i*omega is then 4 minus
omega squared plus i*omega.
And when we put the
pieces together,
we end up with a
particular solution,
which looks like the real part
of 1 over 4 minus omega squared
plus i*omega, F_0 upstairs,
e to the i*omega*t.
So we're asked to compute
the amplitude response graph.
And if we take a
look at this, we
see that the denominator here
is really just a complex number.
So we can convert it into
the form of r e to the i*phi.
Now, the amplitude
response is defined
as the ratio of the output
divided by the input.
And so the output
amplitude is going
to be the magnitude of
this complex number.
So as a result, the amplitude
response is just the magnitude
of 1 over the characteristic
polynomial evaluated
at i*omega.
This is also sometimes referred
to as the complex gain.
Moreover, this term
right here contains
two pieces of information.
Not only does it contain
the amplitude response,
but it also contains
the phase information.
When we take the
absolute value, we're
throwing out the
phase information,
and we're just remembering
the amplitude response.
So what is this
amplitude response look
like for this case?
Well, we have 1 over and it's
the magnitude of this complex
number, which is 4 minus
omega squared plus i*omega.
So I just take the
real part, square it,
add it to the
imaginary part squared,
and square root
the whole quantity.
Now there's a question
of how to graph this.
And we see that first
off, the square root's
an increasing function.
And we see that we're 1
over an increasing function.
So there's a trick,
which is to just
look first at sketching
this piece which
is under the radical sign.
And if you look at trying
to maximize this function--
so finding the critical points--
we'd see that in this case,
we have one maximum, to 4
minus omega squared plus omega
squared.
And this is at when omega
equals the square root of 7/2.
Sorry.
This is a minimum.
So when I go to sketch
this now, we have omega,
we have the amplitude response.
Now, I'm going to draw in 2
from our previous diagram.
Now, the square root
of 7/2 is just below 2,
so square root of 7/2.
So we end up with
a maximum at 7/2,
and then a decay to infinity.
And again, this is going
to be 1/4 when omega is 0.
So this is the peak
amplitude response.
So note that in this case, by
adding damping, what we've done
is we no longer have an
asymptote at omega equals 2.
But we now have a
finite amplitude,
which occurs at omega equals
the square root of 7/2.
So I'm just going to
clean up the board,
and I'll be back with
part c in a second.
For part a, we have an amplitude
response diagram, which
looks like a tent function.
And at 2, omega equals
2, we have a resonance.
So the amplitude
response diverges.
Just like to point out, I
made a small error before.
I forgot to include absolute
values on the denominator here.
The amplitude response
function, it's
always a positive quantity.
We always throw out
any phase information
and leave that for the phase in
the description of the response
of the linear system.
So the amplitude response
is always positive.
For part b, we added
dampening to the system.
And we see that there's
actually a peak point which
is at the square root of 7/2.
And the amplitude response
is bounded at this point,
but it achieves a maximum.
And then again it
decays to infinity.
So I'd like now to
take a look at part c.
And in part c, we have the
differential equation x dot dot
plus 6x dot plus 4x
equals F_0 cosine omega*t.
And again, the amplitude
response is going to equal 1
over the absolute
value of p of i*omega.
And in this case, p of i*omega
is going to be 1 over-- Well,
we still have the 4
minus omega squared term.
Instead of x dot, we now have
6x dot, which gives us 6i*omega.
And then again, we want
to take the absolute value
of this complex number.
And when we take
the absolute value,
we just get the sum
of the real parts
squared plus the sum of the
imaginary parts squared,
which in this case is going
to be 36 omega squared,
the whole quantity
squared rooted,
and then we have
1 over this value.
So now if we'd like
to plot this function,
we can still do the same trick
and try to maximize or find
the critical points of the
denominator under the radical.
And if we did this,
in this case we
would find that the
only critical point
is when omega is equal to 0.
Secondly, if we look at
omega going to infinity,
we see that the denominator
goes to infinity.
So this whole
quantity must go to 0.
So if I were to go back here
to the amplitude response
for part c, again, when
omega is equal to 0
it's going to start off at 1/4.
I've just argued that it goes
to 0 as omega goes to infinity.
And since there are
no critical points,
we must smoothly paste the
function between the two.
And in fact, it's
always decreasing.
So the amplitude
response, in this case,
is just a decreasing function.
So this concludes part c.
And now I'll take
a look at part d.
Discuss the resonance
for each system.
So in part a, we had no damping.
And we saw that there was a
resonance at omega equals 2.
And the resonance
manifested itself
in the amplitude response graph
with a divergent asymptote
at omega is equal to 2.
So as you drive the system
close to omega equals 2,
the amplitude of the
system starts to diverge.
In case two we introduced
damping into the system.
So we still have a very large
amplitude response at omega
equals the square root
of 7/2, however it's
no longer infinite.
And then lastly, when we
increased damping even further
so we had the 6x dot term, the
presence of a peak disappeared.
And in fact, the
amplitude response
just monotonically decayed
from 1/2 to infinity.
So just constantly
decreased to 0.
So I'd just like
to conclude there,
and I'll see you next time.